i'm um in las vegas somewhere
in quarantine getting ready to shoot
shark tank
in the bubble as they say
[Music]
so anyways i'm um in las vegas
somewhere in quarantine somewhere
and uh getting ready to shoot shark tank
real
soon in the bubble as they say
so i'm sitting in my hotel room
as i have been getting tested every 36
hours
going a little crazy beautiful hotel
room
like beautiful but still a prison give a
little tour of my um
um my little prison here
it's a broadcast studio really
you can see all these cameras you can
actually broadcast them here
it's very cool you see all that
it's uh yeah it's it's nice you know
it's i can't go anywhere
shark tank starts season 12 crazy
we're all here somewhere in las vegas
maybe henderson
you know like around and um
in the bubble baby in the bubble so once
they're done
can they leave yeah yeah i mean they
have flights and stuff
so they'll be traveled out but they're
leaving really quickly out there
so this will be their stage wow wow
talk about social distances [ __ ]
hi there
amazing yeah so there
so jillian and their team will be able
to grab an entrepreneur
and then uh meet with uh kenji for
anybody else that needs to talk to them
right outside the store
right great oh it's the think
tank yeah yeah i mean everything else is
crazy but the set looks good
they're all spread out but the circle
doesn't look too spread out
it looks pretty good circle gets a
square does it look on the camera like
it's wider
it doesn't it actually looks like it's
closer really
it looks incredible you guys did an
amazing job the setup for this
you're going to end up using more tight
shots basically did the launcher of all
this
it looks good though yeah very
incredible hey everyone mindy zemrak i'm
the head of casting for shark tank we
are here in las vegas at the venetian
filming season 12.
so thankful to the venetian and their
entire team crew staff everyone our
production
without this we probably wouldn't be
filming um so some things that you're
going to see different this year is
something that is required as we're all
required to wear masks and ppe
so at all times we have to have a mask
on the entrepreneurs
take their mask off right before they
enter the tank and then as soon as
they're exiting the tank
they're given their mask to put back on
all of the sharks have to put on some
sort of mask as well either the ones
that are around their neck
or they have to hold it some things that
are different this year that you're
gonna see
is that the sharks are all sitting six
and a half feet apart for social
distancing um
and the entrepreneurs who typically are
13 feet behind
away from the sharks are now 21 feet the
other thing that you're going to see is
there's
going to be not as many handouts to the
sharks or any because
for safety reasons so everything is
preset by our art department
um and then there's also no uh like
celebratory congratulations or you know
anywhere near the sharks
so if someone makes a deal with a shark
then they can air high-five them
but the sharks can't come close and they
can't go close to the sharks so we're
taking every precaution
uh we're all tested anywhere from three
to five three day every three days or
every four days or every five days
depending on what zone you're in
um so everyone here is very very
protective so i'm gonna get po
go ahead and put my mask back on but
yeah that's just a couple differences of
this season
[Music]
so
[Music]
i will not be any closer to you
get away from me cdc recommends
social distancing six feet away from
each other
right now if work dictates that you have
to work close together that is totally
fine
but please do so at a minimum time okay
no longer than 10 minutes
separate okay of course we're wearing
face masks you see everybody's my face
mask
work dictates if you don't wear face
masks that's totally fine you have the
mask let's see you have the face shields
block
anything that's coming around you all
right sanitizing if at all possible
please wear gloves you can see people
are wearing gloves make sure you're
washing your hands
there's a lot of surfaces that that
around here if you catch yourself
leaning on those surfaces
when you wash your hands the next time
you wash your hands make sure
you're getting those forearms and elbows
okay because we just don't
pay attention
[Music]
mindy castain i feel like you traveled
the world were you in cambodia yesterday
okay
yes listen i happen to know lori is
teeming with death she's teaming with
death
we are six to eight feet apart i don't
know i'm really sad because i can't mess
with him
retails down as much as 50 in terms of
foot traffic so know what you have to do
you have to pivot to digital
you have to set up a website you have to
sell direct to your customer base that
involves understanding
how to produce a great 59 second video
lots of terrific photographs of your
product or service
and the ability to understand which
digital platform
to buy ads on personally i recommend
facebook
geo locked ads so you can test the
region see if your message works and
then expand nationally
but it's all about direct baby direct
direct direct you know why you love that
100 percent margin as opposed to paying
for retail distribution which can be as
much as 50 50
of your profits out the window go direct
avoid
the problems that covet is putting into
distribution and retail
[Applause]
premier uh listen uh i can't thank you
guys enough
uh you should all be proud of what we've
accomplished again we're not done yet
but i know at the end of the day we're
not gonna be able to do this because
we're always like
we gotta finish but um
i wanna say you know on behalf of myself
and you
mgm mark burnett the team sony abc
everybody is so grateful you guys
i'm proud of this accomplishment truly i
mean it's amazing
um can't don't have time to thank
everybody but
i did want to say thank you to everyone
i mean
every person here the only reason we got
through this
is because everybody joined in together
right we all
followed the protocols everybody did it
we always talk about shark tank family
you really saw it during this experience
today so
thank you everybody
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe